to Germany where D Hoonah since nach
Hause ago comment on sushi often that
worry Michelle will translate that for
you all later when angle Merkel
recklessly threw open her country's
borders and declared come one come all
to homeless migrants she was hailed as a
humanitarian hero now weakened by
elections and widely derided by many of
her electorate she's seen as a dumb cop
in a total vault fast how many languages
in this hood she has now set aside tens
of millions of euros to bribe migrants
with cash handouts to go back home they
get the loot to pay for new kitchens or
bathrooms in their homelands rinsable
isn't it yeah fancy a new kitchen in
Kabul gives a few thousand euros towards
the cooker and maybe the fridge
this shows the lunacy of how Europe
dealt with the migrant crisis from being
a land of total order much of Germany is
now riddled with unrest and Chancellor
Merkel is wholly responsible now her
nickname at home is multi that's German
for mother well this was the mother and
father of all errors oh and by the way
the earlier sentence it meant the
chickens are coming home to roost
[Music]
well well done for you German thank you
didn't agree with anything you said I
liked what you said in German I like the
fact that you've come in a European
theme dressed as Inspector Clouseau your
topic and I totally disagree with you
and I think actually I think that this
is a bit of a PR exercise on Merkel's
part I think it's to do with the rise of
the far-right in Germany I think
actually when Merkel took the decision
that she made it showed real leadership
in that it was let me finish in that it
was morally the right thing to do but
also long term the right thing for
Germany because that first wave of
immigrants were those that were from the
educated classes there were lots of
doctors scientists there were there were
the people that could hold you no let me
finish the people that could afford to
actually get on the boats and leave that
first wave where a lot of those were
from the educated classes and actually I
think what we'll see long term is that
there will be a skill shortage that will
be filled by these communities so I
think on the surface it seems like all
she was just doing the nice thing and
and and and being altruistic
but actually long-term for the German
economy I think they'll benefit but just
before I throw them bribing these folks
do you not think it's unfair for these
people as well some of whom have
traversed half of the world to come to a
country where clearly they're not that
welcome so there's a few quickly how
many people actually take up the offer I
really think that this is a PR exercise
great do you think that the political
problem in which she finds herself is
she's still trying to put some form of
government and June rightly mentions the
rise of the far right
she is the architect to use expression I
used to she's the architect of
misfortune to this policy isn't she yes
doesn't mean the policy was wrong but it
is she is the architect of me certainly
so was a politely right um well I I
think my son has lived in the Middle
East for so many years and I haven't
talked to him a lot of the people who
have gone to Germany it's just like a
lot of people will want to go back if
there is sanity again in Libya and if
there's sanity
again in Syria then a lot of these
people will want to go back and if it
means helping them to go back that seems
to me to be highly educated I'm finding
the other thing is that what she knew
about Germany of course is that it's not
replacing its population and therefore
they needed yeah I mean all Western
societies need more young people if
they're gonna pay your pension
yeah they you need more young people now
but actually the bell of the few that
doesn't is this country we've got a
younger population but if you go to
Germany go to Italy now these are places
where they're needed young people now
the motion these are not the wages no
well I think the whole problem of what
happened in those in over those two
summers was that none of us knew how to
cope with movement of numbers on that
sky can I just add to that I think that
Merkel was prepared to fall on her sword
to do what was right for Germany and I
think long-term
we will see that she was right it seems
like a Trojan now trying to put because
you've got arrived do you know why she's
doing this what I'm saying she was
prepared to fall on her sword to do what
was right for that country and we'll see
I want to sell it Michel because I know
you you've got a head for figures and
you wonder why Germans are getting angry
right
imagine your German taxpayer Berlin set
aside 685 million euros for
accommodation for unaccompanied minors
integration programs the idrd our
language lessons they spent 1.3 billion
euros virtually double taxpayers are
gonna get angry when they see money
going that way aren't there was shell I
think that and I said this previously I
think what Angela Merkel did was
completely wrong I understand that she
might have had good intentions I
understand that she might have been
trying to make up for ills of days gone
by or whatever her motives were but I
think the way that she handled that
situation was it would there's no I
don't know I've got very strong words
for it but they're not appropriate for a
TV show it's probably responsible if
you're if you're leading the German
people and you see the reaction it's had
in their undivided towns and cities
completely wrong and when you you know
she didn't have consideration for any
other country for which the the migrant
population would be able to freely go in
so she didn't have any consideration for
the fact that actually he's a very wart
on conflict ridden places that people
were actually who
who were these people there were no
proper secure checks and balances of
people coming in or not coming the whole
thing was in my view terrible let's get
Rachel will come back I have I've I
think it's really hard to see what was
the right thing to do when Syria
conflict displaced what was it my
million years together
Germany is a first world country that
could have given has now given a home to
700,000 people back this is nice so and
now you're now attacking her forgiving
them offering them money to return to
their country which is completely
devastated obviously I think what we
need to have is a european-wide Marshall
Plan which doesn't which doesn't mean
that one country is responsible for
doing all these things no European the
EU has a has allocated set you know a
numbers of asylum seekers and desperate
migrants to be taken in and none of the
countries are stepping up to the plate
certainly where we're not even in the
asylum agreement in the EU
so it's terribly unfair to dump this on
Germany and particularly well they bring
themselves people helmet cheeses like
Syria you're talking with a lot people
had left places like Syria and gone to
places like Turkey so they were out of
majority of them report on yeah but they
were out of that immediate Wharton
danger they weren't you know immediately
had rest of their life and I think what
we did and we were paying Turkey
remember to keep them there in order for
them not to travel into Europe reach
that must it was the biggest population
shift since World War II was young if I
remember but we encouraged that we
encouraged people to endanger their own
life she died by saying open door that's
like what we did wasn't very nice
durable trees amazed for home office
bands that just said go home I mean I
prefer to have a kicker theory
she's just a girl that if you're here
illegally you go home
white vans used to patrol neighborhoods
ever then I shouldn't be in a country
wouldn't use Shh
I mean it wasn't it a humanitarian
gesture where she actually said and she
might have been politically wrong and
the public would she was pretty much in
what we could but it was a humanitarian
gesture said there is a real
humanitarian problem when we as the
richest people by the Jewish people we
is the richest country in Europe we can
help so idea was there I'm sure her
intentions were good yes I'm sure she
had good intentions but she shouldn't
have done what she did that will always
be my son shouldn't sometimes
politicians do things right as opposed
to necessarily what they think is
popular no way my point is she showed
real leadership on this issue far more
than any other European leader and also
actually whenever you have a wave of
mass emigration there is always a Perl
from the native probably derive them to
go with the kitchen when when you had
the Windrush population again right this
photo people were up in arms most
British people didn't want those
immigrants here but long term it
actually be bridesmaid kitchens to go
home that's not the point so my point is
long-term this is going to be good for
Germany and we will see will wish we did
something similar we shall fail and
danke we shall see and it's the